covert 19 is causing a spike in
relationship breakdowns
divorce rates are soaring they would
double the normal rate in wuhan during
the first lockdown
in the u.s they've surged by a third
the pandemic has shrunk our world into
our homes
juggling child care alongside work
being on top of each other 24 7 it's all
proven too much for many couples but
some say it's actually made their bonds
stronger
how can we make pressure cooker
relationships work in these tough times
i'll be talking to a psychology
researcher about that in a few minutes
first crisis aside every third married
couple in germany gets divorced
separation can be prevented by asking
professionals for advice
but you've got to be open to it
[Music]
they've been married for 10 years and
have three children together
jamila and tino's show is all about
their relationship
during the pandemic the highs and the
lows
it's really tight for everyone right now
for the couples and the home life
now more than ever we're dependent on
good communication as a couple and
especially as
parents to organize everything so we can
work
and get through this in good shape
coronavirus lockdowns have put pressure
on couples
working from home and homeschooling have
left partners with very little free time
constantly living on top of each other
can create conflict
and even worsen existing relationship
problems
when couples are at their wit's end
professionals can help
strangely we tend to assume
relationships are something we're simply
able to do and if we can't then we say
the other person is to blame and we
separate or
we're not a good fit i don't believe
that relationships
always have to be easy i believe that
it's possible to get to the stage where
you can have a clear relationship with
each other
and it's no longer difficult to talk
about problematic topics
for some couples going to a therapist is
a big step
a first aid kit for home life this box
contains cards of questions for couples
to ask each other
developed by a professional therapist
many relationships suffer from a
breakdown in communication
this method offers a playful way for
partners to get back into conversation
with each other
[Music]
couples come to therapy feeling
under-appreciated or a lack of
recognition
often they're fighting more and more
getting stuck in repeating thought
patterns
so they come to discuss their everyday
lives how they're bearing the burdens of
life unequally
and now during the coronavirus you also
get boredom a lack of sexuality
or simply that they are just getting on
each other's nerves
demand for therapy has grown but it's
not exactly cheap
a session can cost between 80 and 150
euros
there's no guarantee of success
i think we choose our partners ourselves
and this offers great growth potential
with each other
we grow when we overcome conflicts not
when everything is easy
but couples therapy can give both
partners the support they need
to get through the pandemic
[Music]
psychology researcher raquel peale joins
us from australia now
the report raquel said that we grow when
we overcome conflicts not when
everything's easy but for a lot of us
the question is
what to do in the first place when the
challenge facing us is just too
overwhelming
yeah that's right ben for couples it can
be a really difficult time
spending a lot more time together and
having to face
issues that you have already in your
relationship
and now they they are at your face they
are
something that you have to confront what
happens though when those issues have
become too big when there's
been a communication breakdown obviously
or the relationship's gone toxic
how can couples normalize the situation
or re-establish some sort of link
absolutely they have to go back to the
basics we have to remember why we are
together in the first place so it could
be little things like learning how to
communicate
learning that at times when there is
conflict and you need to be able to
express yourself
it's about how you are feeling as
opposed to using new language
which can put the other person at a
defensive mode
what about something like sex how do you
re-establish something as intimate as
that when you're
both fighting and basically hate each
other at the end of the day
yes no you're absolutely right sex is
really important and we are
intrinsically motivated to
seek intimacy and sex is how we are
intimate
but what i would say is if you are a
conflict with your partner you're not
going to be able to go straight to sex
especially if that is it might be the
reason why you are in conflict in the
first place so you might have to start
with small gestures such as sitting
together on the couch
holding hands sitting closer touching
each other so
you might have to again go back to
basics and start with gentle touches
to then be able to go all the way to sex
again
so it's the the little things that
counts and i guess a lot of patience
absolutely a lot of patience and
learning to walk again
in your relationship i'd also just like
to add sexual health has a direct impact
on our
general health doesn't it absolutely
again because we are seeking to be
intimate
sex is how we do it so it does have a
huge impact in how
we understand ourselves and how we rate
ourselves worthy of our partners
so feeling sexy or feeling wanted is a
huge part of our relationships
and it is something that we actually
have to talk to our partners about
so if for some reason you're not having
sex in your relationship
and it's making you feel down about
yourself
it is something that you have to bring
out because it is part of who we are it
is part of our self-esteem
why is sex and private time with a
partner or loved one
so important in a pandemic
well again in a pandemic it becomes more
obvious because we're spending a lot
more time
together so all these conflicts all
these little
kinks in our relationships become quite
obvious and we have to address it so
if there is conflict and you're not able
to have sex
then it becomes obvious that you have to
talk about it and a lot of us actually
find it difficult to address the issue
it's a hard one to talk about raquel
tell me though how can we avoid
getting into this situation in the first
place within a relationship
look it just goes back to communication
and and thinking that
even though we think we know our partner
we think we know how it is to be in a
relationship
it doesn't hurt to stop and analyze how
we could do it better
to communicate and take it step by step
sometimes going back to the drawing
board and saying how can i do things
differently
and listen if you are going to your
partner with a question how can i be
better how can i do
things differently what are you
expecting to change it's actually being
able to listen
as well very interesting stuff raquel
and a lot for me to definitely listen to
and take on board
thank you very much for joining us
raquel peale there from ipswich
in australia thank you for having me ben
some great solutions there from raquel
but now it's your chance to ask the
questions
keep sending them into our youtube
channel and our science correspondent
derek williams will do his best to
answer them
how likely you to catch kovid 19 outside
for example
from someone running by for me
one of the most striking aspects of this
pandemic
is the amount of research that's gone
into trying to answer
seemingly simple questions like this
which
turn out to actually be pretty
incredibly
complex i mean who would have guessed
even a year ago
that we'd have gotten so obsessed with
the highly
abstract world of aerosol distribution
physics both in enclosed rooms
and outside back to the question though
we
we now know that while it certainly
might be possible to catch
covet 19 outdoors it's much
much less likely than it is indoors in
poorly ventilated spaces where
people spend extended periods of time
that's because unlike outdoors
aerosols accumulate in enclosed spaces
and increase the chance that you might
inhale enough
of of what an infected person has
exhaled
to catch the disease so though that's an
amount
i'd like to note by the way that we we
still don't know
with any certainty um in general
the consensus seems to be that in
addition to the
indoors outdoors aspect of the equation
the other factors that play major roles
in infection are how long
exposure lasts how how close
an infected person comes to you and
the amount of time that you're around
them um
the who only recommends masks and
outdoor settings where physical
distancing
can't be maintained like crowds
and not for people doing intense
physical activity
that's because pretty much all the
indicators point to the conclusion
that the jogger panting by you in the
park
just doesn't really present that big of
a risk
[Music]
derek williams there good advice as well
i wouldn't mind going for a jog after
work
briefly in other corona related news
though
more countries are suspending their role
out of the astrazeneca vaccine
following the example of norway and
denmark on thursday
denmark made the call after reports of
severe blood clots after patients
received the shot
no definitive link between the jab and
the clots have yet been
proven the danish health and medicines
authority says it's issuing a two-week
halt out of precaution as it
investigates further
the european medicines agency has
approved johnson johnson's vaccine for
use in the european union
the single dose shot is the fourth to be
licensed across the 27 eu nations
authorities hope that a one-dose vaccine
will help speed up
the stalled roll out of covert jabs here
in europe
and fancy a texas tea after knocking off
work that is
unmasked texas has lifted its mask
mandate
and capacity restrictions on restaurants
and other businesses
that's despite experts warning the
hundred percent relaxation of curbs will
exacerbate the spread of worrying
variants
the pandemic has hit the united states
the hardest the infection rate has
fallen dramatically since january but
remains high
in absolute terms
thank you for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
you